good evening members
thank you um
welcome to this overview and scrutiny uh
committee acting does crime disorder on
the 2nd of March
my name is councilor Michael helm
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you to speak at the proper
time please note that the YouTube live
streams sound recording is dependent on
the correct use of the microphone
therefore can I ask that when you
invited to speak you remember to turn on
your microphone and turn it off when
you're finished please reference a page
or paragraph number when referring to
the agenda papers and keep your
contributions clear and concise
um apologies for absence I bet it would
be it's councilor Bill and councilor
Bell against the brown Bill and cast a
bill
right the minutes of the last meeting
held on the
what's the date
24th of January 24th of January
can be found on pages nine two wherever
uh ISO move do I have a secondary for
that motion
does any member wish to raise a uh
Council hurt
do you want to ring okay
right any decorations of Interest
[Applause]
counselor Hood
um thank you chairman uh just to declare
that my son is a serving police officer
and I'm also a member of the police and
crime panel
no I'm not
thank you thank you for that uh public
participation is there any public
participation please
correctly
I'll move on to item
sixth the report presented by Spencer
Clark
thank you chair
um for those who don't know me I'm
Spencer Clark I'm the community safety
manager at Malden District
um I have uh circulated a report in
advance so what I intend to do is just
go through the Australian points of that
report
um and I'll go for it Page by page if
that's okay chair
um that's fine so um on page one
um just informing members of
statutory duties of the partnership and
uh just to inform that we're in the
process of completing what's called our
strategic assessment for Malden that
will be presented to the responsible
authorities group on the 23rd of March
which is only in a three weeks time
um so what we've done is uh as per
previous years we've gone through a data
review and gone through a crime risk
Matrix scoring exercise
that was a partnership exercise which
included the Chief Inspector sitting
next to me this evening
um just uh just to go through the
headline priorities there's not likely
to be any major changes from last year
just some changes to the The Narrative
which is based on current risks
um
and that aligns with the police
Commissioners police and crime plan and
the Essex crime prevention strategy
um we also been working on some other
data that operation Minerva data so
um
fire HQ on Monday uh establishing some
areas of risk for molden around female
victimization so it's a new mapping tool
we're looking at so that's another thing
which will impact on priorities so on
3.12 there you'll see what the proposed
priorities will be one of the major
changes around that is um
what we will have to include is around
uh serious violence because this new
serious violence Duty comes in
um
this year so the the statutory detailed
guidance for the Syrian surveillance
Duty was released on the 16th of
December but
um this particular piece of work will be
carried out by the Essex violence and
vulnerability unit since they have a
analyst so they'll produce a strategic
needs assessment for Essex but with a
molden section on it so that's one of
the new duties coming in so you'll see
you'll see that the five priorities are
um not changing much from previous years
um I think one thing which we've flagged
up in a number of meetings which we do
need to do a bit more work around and I
spent a couple of hours at Malden fire
station this afternoon
um around uh fatal fires and uh how we
can reduce uh those because we've had
about three in molten District in the
last 18 months or so and they've all
been very similar scenarios so we will
be doing some further work around that
so uh you'll you'll see under 3.13 how
they align with the corporate plan which
is obviously changed in uh very very
recently but when this was actually
offered and uh we have a clear action
plan which red Amber green rates all of
the projects being done around that
um this was a recommendation from an
intern award in 2020
um actually just completed uh internal
World on community safety
um which will be
looked at our audience governance
meeting this in a week's time in this
very room so that will be published soon
after that
um I won't say too much about police
performance because uh Chief Inspector
Ballard's going to talk about that in
detail but you'll see that
um the performance figures from Oldham
were circulated in my report so they
were the most up-to-date ones
um so I won't say any more around that
um under 3.15
um
an update on prevent
um as I as I've mentioned before I chair
the Essex County prevent group and
report back to uh the Essex contest
board and also to safer Essex so uh did
that last week
um
the local counter-terrorism local
profile was only released just over a
week ago and there's no real change to
the risks to
um molden and Essex really the current
UK threat remains substantial and we're
still doing plenty of work around the
prevent agenda
um
what we have started doing was is doing
some more work around upskilling other
partners around that and you also see
that the independent Advisory Group
continues to meet as well and we look at
some of the tactics used like things
like talking about Community detentions
hate crime and policing interventions
such as stop and search
so uh
on that final bit there you'll see that
finally the shore cross review was
published on the 8th of February and I'm
not intending to go through the full
details of the shore cross review
tonight I have put a link in there for
any members who are interested there's
about 34 recommendations on how prevent
should be changed and there's a real one
of the main things is talk taking away
the word vulnerable and using the word
susceptible so people who are
susceptible to radicalization so but I
will go into full detail about that
tonight but I'm happy to provide a brief
in note to members another opportunity
if you're interested
so we're forward scanning you see
they're up under 3.16 um I already spoke
about the serious violence Duty uh where
we're doing the work around that and
there's some of you may be aware that
the final Manchester inquest report was
fun the full finders was published today
so uh the protect Duty or was no which
will be known as Martin's law will come
into Force
um with the draft legislation being
available in Spring this year there have
been a number of uh sessions already
around that and officers have already
attended those but uh we're not going to
guess what the legislation will be
although we've got a very good idea but
that will be really about making sure
we've got competent persons uh trained
for our spaces so as a district council
we know if we're doing events in places
like Promenade Park it'll be sensible to
have uh staff trained to a certain level
um
also you'll see that safer Essex agreed
the pan Essex Duty and as I already said
about the Strategic local needs
assessment being done and how that will
link to the other areas and there's also
a full review of community safety
Partnerships uh which is being done at
the moment as well which is one of the
pfcc's uh areas this is something which
started last year but uh due to changes
in government
um a number of these uh projects have
sort of slowed up but I think we'll be
seeing them gain in Pace again in the
coming months
under 3.2 just an update on what's been
happening
um
at the pfcc's uh office
um you'll you'll see that um
the police in precept has been agreed
and I put a link in there so that um
members can uh
um look at that and see where the
increases if so there's been a small
increase in the policing precept but
also a small increase in the fire
precept as well there's a link in there
with the more detail around that and
you'll see that the funding for this
current year will be the same as what we
got last year and uh we had a when I say
we had an annual view Mr Holmes and
myself had a annual review with the
pfcc's office to
uh check that everything's in order and
uh going smoothly
so um
also flag in under 3.23 about the Royal
crime event
um so it was a lot of focus on Rural
crime uh so it's an event at Leia Marley
tower on the 10th of March uh if any
people like to attend that
and
um
under 3.2
um just flagging up around the policing
numbers but again I won't say too much
in detail about that because I know
Chief Inspector Ballard is going to pick
that up in his report
3.24 is about the work of the violence
and vulnerability unit
um as I say we do a lot of close work
with that unit I
um sit uh on behalf of Essex as the one
of the representatives on the operations
uh board which is chaired by Mr profit
who's the deputy chief constable and one
of the pieces worked on recently is uh
to remove the knife amnesty bin from the
fan to the Civic offices
and I see a big sigh of relief by most
members here and uh We've replaced it at
Promenade Park which is a more
appropriate location it's a a it's
a smaller unit which is in fact the size
of a wheelie bin because there is a
wheelie bin inside it which makes it a
lot easier to empty and that's emptied a
couple of times a year so that that's
that that unit has uh been jointly
funded by the violence and vulnerability
unit and uh
um the Malden Community safety
partnership
onto just a 3.3 is really just an update
of uh what's what's been uh going on uh
in terms of this year we'll be producing
a action plan for the coming year going
forward but I think you'll see but see
that we've achieved most of the things
we wanted to do in this current year and
a little bit more
um you'll see that
um we still treat missing and child
exploitation very seriously I attend the
mace one and the mace 2 meetings and uh
we have a close working relationship
with the schools and you also see that
I've just listed some of some of the
meetings we attend there's a vast amount
of meetings which we attend where where
we do joint working across the whole
partnership
again under 3.3 free I'm not going to
say too much about that because it's a
in in the policing area as such but just
commend the work of the community safety
engagement officer PC Rosie Smith who is
Malden's officer does some really good
work in the community and more
importantly some excellent
Communications which is something which
I think we've all been looking to
improve on in recent years and I think
we're we're nearly there with that one
um and uh
just flagging up some of the hot spots
um where
it's beef had been 80 anti-social
Behavior or uh drug misuse drug nuisance
um and some of the works we've been
doing around that and flagging again
around the Essex fire and rescue work
we're doing around uh fatal fires and
we're also uh doing the safe well and
secure visits
um at the end of May which will be a
partnership initiative knocking on lots
of doors in Malden District
um to uh promote fire safety and rescue
plans in properties
3.35 Flags around crucial crew
we opened the booking for crucial crew
this year
um I think we had six six Schools sign
on in the first half day of it being
open so it's obviously a very
um important intervention for the
schools and we'll be working with tick
box Productions again who producer a
drama on exploitation and awareness
around knife crime and drugs this has
been booked for the 13th the 15th of
June for this coming year so I said then
we've already got people uh booked onto
it
just also flag in a vast number of
events we've got I think we got back to
uh following the sort of easing of the
pandemic as such got back to the real
Community engagement this year and we
tried to get into US many areas as we
could whether it's bike marking whether
it's working with our Crime Stoppers
colleagues such as councilor hibner over
there we've done plenty of uh work in
the community uh working with a variety
of part partners and uh most of the
events we've done have been pretty well
attended we've done the senior safety
event again at Malden Stadium which was
well attended and uh
just lots of uh joint working going on
there you'll see that the youth strategy
group have also put in some uh
um work in terms of Dramas around uh the
unacceptable drama went into the schools
last last year but in this current year
and you'll see finally there we also
I've listed just
a few of the projects which we do
throughout the year I think we were the
first area to do a street week in uh
Essex that was really well attended so
it was almost like so many different
interventions by the police include
including there I think councilor Hebrew
and myself had a day in Malden High
Street didn't we which is
lots of stuff around that loads of
public engagement
you'll see that true cam uh is really uh
still being done in lots of parishes and
we've uh in the process of purchasing a
new unit for that so it will improved
the capability of what we're doing
around traffic enforcement
one of the things uh we have to do as
the district is meet our prevent Duty
um I do that on behalf of the behalf of
Essex last year we scored free which
means the standards met
free is a good score for a
unfunded area because we're not funded
by the home office to do anything around
preventing violent extremism I went
through the scoring process with the
home office again last week I think
we'll probably score three again
although we are scoring four in some
areas so one of one of the big changes
we've now got an Essex
situational risk assessment which looks
at the risk to Essex and more
importantly has an action plan to
mitigate risks so that that's that's
been complete again for this year
um but I won't go into all this in
detail but you'll see that there's
plenty going on I think one of the one
of the good areas for Malden and I spent
a couple of hours with him earlier today
is the try service pilot so Les Davis
who is uh
um does so much work in the community
um again we're arranging that safe well
and secure uh piece of work with him at
the end of May
um
again
um just going through this area lots of
community engagement lots of work with
schools
lots of uh work around interventions
with young people whether it's been
healthy relationships whether it be an
exploitation awareness we even done and
another area been doing quite a bit of
work in molding around is working with
the business crime team so when we've
done the street weeks they were knocking
on most of the shop doors in Malden High
Street and also where we add up snowy
just before Christmas where we're based
at Tesco's given advice around safety
and and fraud so that's really quickly
in a nutshell without going into too
much detail about what's been going on
on behalf of the partnership this year
and and the conclusion there about the
ongoing
joint work and how that's been going
quite nicely and and I think that when
the audit report is published next week
that will uh summarize that the work of
the partnership is going quite well but
say that's that won't actually be
published or seen by the committee until
next Thursday okay thank you very much
for that any questions members
yes
hi thanks thanks Spencer um
so looking at um page nine and that
3.1.2 of the report where we've got the
um priorities the five priorities
something that I did notice and
obviously I'm you know I've only been a
member for a year and I've looked around
this report and and the um
appendices with it but promoting road
safety and challenging irresponsible
driving is one of the five priorities
and I can't find all that much compared
to all the other priorities on that work
and I can see that you've got the
reference to True cam which you've just
spoken about and I'm guessing that maybe
a crucial crew or something else you'd
you you talk to young people about
driving but I can't see any figures to
us as to how we're getting on with that
I don't know if I've missed them
somewhere but um can you give us any
update on on the road situation
most certainly can't suspensely so
um usually when uh most Partnerships uh
uh choose their priorities they choose
them on data
um one thing which also always flags up
for Malden District is around
perceptions so this this priority is
really much in there as a result of the
perceptions of the public uh though who
feel quite strongly about Road Safety
um obviously there's a data to back that
so it's a as a district council we do a
lot of work around true cam
but in addition to that
um the police also do a lot of work
around that and I I and I'd able to
still the chief inspectors funder
because I know in part of his slides IT
addresses some of the work they've been
doing around it
also when we've done the street week
it's not just uh Community engagement it
also is traffic enforcement
um the community engagement team do very
close work with the rural engagement
team so they'll look at things like
waste carriers licenses Etc and uh the
fire service do an incredible amount of
work as well so in going into schools
giving advice
um and also the safer Essex roads
partnership so uh I think perhaps it's a
something we could tackle as a subject a
future committee where we could the the
this this this report is skims over a
lot of the work we do but doesn't go
into the explicit detail of What's Done
by the whole partnership and I think
what we need to remember is when we're
considering the community safety
partnership it's not just modern
District Council and Essex police it's
also Essex fire service the probation
service Health you know so so perhaps
and as I always say and uh and put
invitations out to other other members
of the partnership Mr Mr pipe come along
through the from the safer Essex roads
partnership about must have been about a
year ago now and gave a very good
presentation on that
I think it because it is a as well a
public um
please say it would be really good to
have um Mr Puck to come back and
actually do another presentation and to
have that because I think you know the
roads are are a big concern for people
it's something that you hear a lot so
that would be really fantastic and can I
sneak a second question in
orderly and then councilor um Morgan
yes sir thank you chairman and uh thank
you Spencer for the report
um and I commend actually the the amount
that you're doing uh and uh I'm very
very pleased to see that I've got a
number of questions for to inspector
Ballard but I'll wait until until I've
had that uh until I've had that
presentation just one point that I
wanted to to make
um you spoke about the rise in the
precept which has been uh imposed by the
the police and crime commissioner I
wouldn't say it's a small one 15 pounds
um for police and five pounds for
um the fire service
on a band D and uh that's quite a
considerable leap
however
um
I just wanted to on page nine at the
moment uh the
second point is driving down anti-social
behavior in public places and the
figures for Malden will show a fall of
in anti-social behavior and that's great
news
um
but if that has now been achieved I'm
wondering if that should still be a
priority obviously we're working towards
zero uh I think in a perfect world
um but I just wondered
and it may be a question for Chief
Inspector Ballard but
uh does nuisance Behavior fly tipping a
neighbor dispute are they recorded as
anti-social Behavior or are they
recorded as something else because if
they are recorded as something else
their anti-social Behavior will will
fall because they were previously
recorded as such so that's my first
question
yeah you better do so so uh I'll I'll
leave it for the Chief Inspector to
answer
his views on antisocial behavior from a
District Council employee
I don't think I've seen any reduction in
anti-social Behavior so these are
policing statistics we're looking at
here and uh as you're probably aware in
the last three years have been a little
bit skewed with the pandemic whereby
things like covered breaches were sent
anti-social Behavior through the roof
I'd like to think by this time next year
those figures should level off somewhat
and we'll get a true reflection of
what's happening around antisocial
behavior
um we we as a partnership are still
getting the neighbor nuisance
um in fact I haven't got figures in
front of me but um
where people
still have hybrid work in and work from
home a lot more they tend to see a lot
more and they tend to report a lot more
and if from my experience people were
Leicester lesser
um you know
that they they they will that that sort
of Trend will continue with people still
working from home and people being
probably less tolerant with their
neighbors so when they used to be at
work five days a week not not having
those uh problems going on so so
and else in terms of fly tipping I mean
I don't think we've seen any reduction
in fly tipping I think we've probably
seen an increase in fly tipping
um and uh it's something which we in the
environment agency still tackle
um so it I I think it might be useful to
drill into a bit more detail about
anti-social Behavior but we we still see
problems in public areas
you've seen the areas which I've
highlighted where in some of our
villages we still experience it's places
like tollsbury and tillingham South
Minster we still see the youth nuisance
in public places
and it's not just a responsibility for
the police to deal with that we have
other agencies like our community
engagement office we've got youth
workers you know who also will go and do
Outreach in areas where we see hot spots
for example so I I think it's it would
probably be a good idea to
um do a bit more of an analysis around
antisocial Behavior as a partnership we
we still think it should be in there
because we still will continue to tackle
youth nuisance because we know that
youth nuisance can escalate into other
things such as serious violence and
things like that so it's important that
we tackle it at source rather than
before it gets worse
okay and can I just come back on on
another thing then Mr one please okay I
have got another question but I mean
should I ask it now yeah go on okay
right councilor he doesn't mind waiting
um yeah thank you thank you very much
for for that response but um the other
question that I wanted to know about was
uh the the
um how pleased I am that the knife bin
has been moved now
um I did speak to you beforehand about
actually how many weapons were recovered
from this Malden bin I know that over
the county there were 16 tons of
weapons altogether
um but we didn't we never did know how
much there there was from that bin which
is why I was Keen to have it moved
um because I think that it would be
better cited elsewhere rather than right
outside the police station right outside
the offices so do we have any of those
local figures at all
counselor I don't I don't have those
figures to hand I am more than happy to
speak to the police commissioner's
office to see if there's a breakdown of
those figures and particularly when when
the next uh visit which I think will be
in June uh if if they don't record them
um if they record just an Essex total
I'll ask if they can break it down per
bin for the next one thank you I do know
that I think when we when we looked at
it last year it was almost full the mold
and Bin and we were quite surprised that
the number of
um weapons which were put in there but
I'll see if I can ask that question for
future reference thank you thank you Jim
first of Ally thank you chairman
um yes uh thank you for the report
um
going back to schools last time we were
here we were discussing about
I suppose tackling Grassroots like
you've been doing but there was mention
that when you go into schools or the
police go into schools sometimes the
attitude
of of the staff they get worried about
you know why are you there and things
like that do you think that's changing a
bit now or since we last met or how do
you think it's gone
it's a bit of a tough question really
because it it can be very dependent on
schools because and and the makeup of
the areas and it depends what you're
going to be wanting to deliver there so
uh I as you as you know I cover chunks
and mold and so in terms of
secondary schools we've got about 14 or
15 that would cover and uh I know if I
go to certain schools and say I want to
talk to you about gangs they might not
be that interested but if they want to
talk if I go in there and say we're
doing some sessions on Online safety
they'll bite my hand off for it so so it
really does does it does really depend
on what area we're looking at
um but most most schools are
a lot a lot of the areas which we cover
now are now in the phse curriculum so
things like healthy relationships the
schools have to do something around that
now you know so last year when we went
in with the youth service and done the
dramas on unacceptable around uh an
unwanted sexual behavior and misogyny
and things like that they have to tackle
that now so and I I think uh I mean one
of the things I'd like to do for molden
this year is uh perhaps a look at doing
a strategy around violence against women
and girls which we can then take take in
and get signed up to as well so it
the response we get from primary schools
is really good I think last year I think
we had almost every Primary School sign
up to the crucial crew so they have
either come to a live performance or had
a virtual performance the live
performance is much better because the
interaction with the young people they
spent two and a half hours after the
actual performance exploring things like
what you've done if you spoke to a
trusted adult what you've done if you
spoke to a teacher or a police officer
so the the primary schools are very
engaging
um and uh you know so normally it's
quite good
but it is you know they're one
depends on the subject sometimes the
subject matter
Castle Morgan
yeah thank you Mr chairman uh first I'd
just like to live Echo councilor
spenceley's uh point about the promoting
of road safety and and the challenge of
irresponsible driving that is certainly
the major concern uh in the war that I
represented Wickham Bishop wooden
um and if indeed everyone must be will
be on Shore highly relieved to hear that
I completed my own speed watch training
today so I'll be joining the uh during
the fight tomorrow uh what I would what
I would like to know on that point is
that there was a suggestion I think in
the the last report we had that due to
the pandemic Etc that speedwatch had
walked a lot of those teams had fallen
away and be interested to know you know
whether that's picking up and the second
point I'd like to pick up with you is
you mentioned fly tipping
um
I'm sure you may be aware that
um I think it's at the end of this month
the
um recycling centers will be requiring
you to book in to actually
um you know recycle your your very and
only one vehicle I think it's one
vehicle per day will be permitted one
one visit per day will be permitted now
that is likely to lead to a considerable
increase in Flight epic and I wonder if
you've had any sort of plans in place to
to counter that
see counselor
okay happily passes to my director who's
got a response for you on that one
counselor
thank you chairman yes we we are aware
of this this is um effectively a trial
by the County Council so we have been in
um contact basis County Council Waste
Services and expressed our concerns
um they've been running a pilot down in
Riley uh for probably about a year now
and they they believe they'd haven't
seen an increase in Flight living in
that area obviously we do monitor fly
tips we've got a contractor that's
responsible for clearing them so we've
asked them to take particular attention
to what type of materials are being
tipped also to compound the issue now in
terms of furniture furniture can't be
disposed in the normal way so that has
to be collected especially especially
and you recall members agreed an extra
fee in charge for that but there's a
risk that furniture could start to be um
deposited as well so we're very much
aware of that and and the teams in the
community engagement team will be sort
of monitoring that with our street sync
contractor
um that's that's great news I'm glad to
hear that but I'm just wondering I mean
quite often fly tipping sites are used
there is they use again and again is
there any sort of a sort of where the
CCTV or something could be used to
monitor these sites and hopefully try
and prosecute some of the people that's
carrying out this work
german yes sir absolutely so we use lots
of uh tools out the box to do that and
the CCTV is one of those um I can assure
you that we do follow up and obviously
the evidence is looked and then a lot of
times we obviously do a lot of work but
actually can't track it down but um
there are a number of tips that actually
do have information that can lead to a
uh a follow-up um and obviously we will
take action so that that is the part of
the team's activity
okay suspensely and then councilor heard
thank you chair
um so I've got a couple of questions one
is a very quick question which I'll just
get and then I'll go into my other
question on um page 11 at 3.2.4 and I
noticed and I had noticed this uh
previously when I'd read through this
the first time but it talks about the
joint purchase of jet skis in multi in
multiple and I was I thought it was only
one so I just wanted to check on that
because I went to the launch of the
jointly purchased jet ski in a different
capacity and I just wanted whether that
was right or not so that was just one
thought and then the thing that I I
really wanted to ask a question on and I
I will come back after as I do have a
few questions as you know from uh from
councilor Stapp who really wanted to be
here but my own question is
um regarding so it's mentioned
throughout the report and there's an
example at page 10 at 3.1.4 and and the
last part of that power paragraph where
you say the council's community
engagement officers have been doing
joint patrols with Essex police and
other agencies during these busy periods
and not being parochial here but I I
know that for example haybridge Parish
Council is not
um using the services of the community
engagement team anymore and I do believe
that you may be able to correct me that
that's also applicable now to to another
Parish or that another parish is
considering that I don't know this is
what I've heard so with that in mind I
just wanted to be clear about what the
position was if we have a town or Parish
Council anywhere disengage from the
community engagement team what actually
happens with regards to those patrols
because they're obviously quite crucial
for the local community so thank you
to Spencer so obviously we operate a
community engagement team Council as a
sort of core service that it has here
and we also offer that service out to
parishes but I really want to give an
assurance whether a parish is is using
those facilities and those Services
um we still operate in the whole of the
Morton District so Spencer's team will
be looking at the whole of the district
it doesn't matter whether we have a
extra arrangement with the community
engagement team so for those marriages
that don't choose to use that service it
shouldn't impact on anything to do with
anti-social Behavior policing activity
or worker that um safety partnership but
I don't know especially you could add
anything to that
the work of the community safety
partnership uh will will focus on risk
if there was a big anti-social Behavior
public for example we'd look at putting
an intervention in there we'd do joint
patrols like we do with either the
police the youth service or the trial
service pilot officer no Mr Le
Parliament here
um so yeah no that that would make no
difference at all in terms of the the
jet ski question I think there are two
two were purchased to cover up areas not
just Malden so some of the other
districts contributed as well didn't I
if I recall correctly
chairman yes we've got a bit of project
running so we have the the equipment so
you saw one absolutely but there's
another um they're also used by the
river River Police Unit yeah
fantastic and there's one I'll come back
with the questions actually from um
councilor stamp who as I say did ask
myself and the chair to be here but has
been able to unattend to attack sorry
unable to attend and a simple forward a
few questions
um so these are counselor stamps
questions not my own
um talking about do you have any funding
for Town councils
um years ago Burnham Town Council
received some when they bought picnic
tables and chairs for the park do you
have anything like that and where can
Lost Property be left in towns and
villages
um why not she suggests using local
parish and town councils to be a base
for it how often very specific question
how often do you Patrol in Burnham and
the Dengue and there's also a question
with regard to whether or not
um drug dealing is any longer a priority
in Burnham she suspects though that it
isn't so I'll put those questions
forward on cancer stance behalf thank
you I think I should refer to the whole
District not just Burnham
so so I'm not quite sure I understand
the initial one about the funding
benches and things
um so so you know the community safety
partnership will
um look at
funding
projects which might have a community
safety intervention such as a a knife
bin or perhaps perhaps something like a
Youth Shelter is something which would
be up for consideration where we could
somewhere where we could engage with
young people for example so you know I
think I think Community safety projects
you know we we fund quite a things like
merchandise for our events where you
know like uh
purse bowels and the car I can't
remember the name of the boxes I'm sure
if councilor Hebrew will remember stop
your car being stubborn I can't remember
but you know so things like that I mean
I think things like a benching apart
probably wouldn't be a community safety
type function to to fund
um with regard to patrols and in terms
of I won't I won't say anything about
police in patrols because the Chief
Inspector will pick up on that around
that but you know in terms of
partnership patrols we still
give it probably an equal amount of
patrolling in all areas across the
district
um and in terms of uh the question
around drug misuse is it still a
priority yes it most certainly is I
think we've got drug use and drug
trafficking within the district
um so that will continue to be a
priority and but uh but I will let the
Chief Inspector uh report back on that
one since he is the resident expert
sitting next to him
Chancellor heard you had one more
question then councilor um sorry to have
a second bite in the Cherry gem but uh
I've written copious notes Here I just
missed this one on page nine uh
Spencer could I just take you to that
again it's your the priorities the first
one says tackling crime and reducing
offending
um with an emphasis on violent crime
gangs drug trafficking Etc
what does tackling crime mean
because it's I mean how can the
community safety tackle crime
I wasn't quite it's more of an
aspiration than a priority that's why
that's why I asked
um
yeah I mean
I think it's what it means tackling
crime we do you know cry we will do use
what tactics we need to reduce crime
perhaps reduce an attempt to reduce
crime might be a better way of saying it
I think it might be if I might it might
be better to take out tackling crime
altogether and just say reduce
reoffending buy because I'm not quite
sure what the tackling crime
means that's why that's really why why I
asked it but by all means I think what
we'll do is we'll put that to the
response to authorities group when it
meets in three weeks time and they can
take a view on on how that how the
description is done reduce some
reoffendings of statutory Duty for all
Partnerships so that has to stay in
there well I should it's declare an
interest I'm on the responsible
authorities group
sorry sorry
okay thank you
I'll take Council Bill next because she
hasn't spoken at all this evening
suppose instead of cycling crime we
should be here
dealing with crime but there you go
um the other thing I want to mention was
the fly tipping who do we report that to
because I know where there's a fly tip
just outside of goldanger
you know the big big house on that big S
Bend just after that where there's a
sign for gold hang is on the other side
of goldhanger on the entrance of the
field it's just it's been there months
Jim there is an email address for
reporting um fly to be and I think
there's a fresh service ticket as well
but I will share that with members of
the committee and give me the correct
address and also the haybridge parish
council although we don't use the Malden
District Community whatever they call
ourselves we've got our own Community
Support Officer in Gary Dyer
and he does a lot of good work
you know I can't think of anything else
fossilization crept in there
did you want to answer that or is it
self
Yeah well yeah just somewhere where
we're aware of that and obviously if
there's any local initiatives and Joint
working need to be done well happy to do
that thank you so councilor Morley
yes thank you just just a quick I'm
ready to come back on fly tipping again
um I think it'd be helpful in future
News Bulletin not bulletins um circulars
and things that actually the producer of
the waste is also liable for prosecution
as well so although the fly tip is at
fault
is the duty of care they you know to
check that their waste is being disposed
of so I think if people actually
understood that a bit more and they
might get a bit worried you know so
and yes sofas and mattresses are getting
expensive to dispose of I agree but I
just think as long as people realize I
don't think they quite realize but
thank you
anyone else
the other thing is
we were just talking about
can't take furniture and whatever you
get to the Civic immunity Center or
outside of the street the dump
um basically
with all of this furniture
I mean I've seen the prices now of what
modern District Council charge to take
it away
it's pretty horrendous for what it is
it's like per item and whatever one to
three and three to six
and when it was getting up to like 144
Rod Panda or something for about 12
items I went oh my God
you know it was getting a little bit
heavy and I I can honestly see that
increasing tipping
I mean you know you see any skip oh
councilor Morley will tell you there's
always a mattress on it
yes unfortunately it does reflect the
cost of disposal just wanted to just
pick up on the point that regarding
about not being able to take sofas to
the uh the county
um recycling sites you can so that's one
of the places you if you can get it
there and you can still take it and they
will receive it
um the council will still take it away
but it has to Levy a charge because it
has to be handled and stored in a
different way and that's what the issue
is with waste carriers because they
would potentially have to carry it in
separate vehicles not mix it with other
so that's why it's become more difficult
and more expensive but we are fully
aware there's a risk and we all can do
is monitor the situation but this is um
a legislation that's been brought in
I think for anyone else
is that report noted
right
we'll move on now to uh
Chief Inspector Paul
Ballard is that right correct
Ballard right I'll hand over to you now
foreign
good evening councilors thank you chair
um I'll try my best to operate this both
over my shoulder and in front of me on a
small a smaller screen so hopefully I've
got my glasses I've got my glasses on so
we'll go through this um you'll see
hopefully you'll be able to see so
um this presentation has been prepared
for me by my community safety engagement
officer and also my account center team
Sergeant at the community policing team
with some some assistance from the rural
engagement team you'll see some slides
at the end so you know counselors you
you'll be aware that the rural
engagement sorry the town center team at
Malden is a relatively new team it's an
uplift team that was brought in
following the pfcc's um Direction around
the upset uplifting in town center teams
and Malden was one of the teams that was
put in place that wasn't there
previously
um they are relatively new in policing
terms when we go back to some of the
established um
policing models that we have around the
county
um to being in since October is
relatively new so we are still seeing
the the burgeoning effects and um impact
of them as we move through into this
part of the heat of the Year and that
said
um I think and and the feedback I've
certainly been getting um is that
they've got off to a really good start
within the district not just in their
engagement but also the work that
they've been conducting and on this
slide you'll see that there's some
examples of some of the work and and
some of the places that they've been I
won't list them you know you're all able
to see where they've been but you can
see some very
um nice pictures some of them are the
back of people's we take we try to get
the front but um they tend to try and
get away from us when we try and take
pictures of them when they're walking
but um but yeah so you'll see that
obviously we are getting into as many um
areas of the district as we possibly can
and to be as visible and to increase our
engagement as much as we are able within
the communities
um additionally
um we we obviously take opportunities to
work closely with partner agencies from
other um engagement events and offer
crime prevention advice and relative
materials to to those that might need
them at various different locations that
are prominent within local communities
and we also attend local schools and
nurseries as well as other groups that
may congregate and meet in order to
engage with a wider selection of the
community in a diverse and spread out
fashion as possible
um we also work very much in partnership
with modern District Council to run bite
marking events in 99 days in order to
engage with the public
um and then we've got a little bit
further on the school visit so the
school visits and the engagement with
younger members so each um each
secondary school has a an allocated
officer which is in their point of
contact in regards to engaging with them
and and we also do an awful lot of work
with the uh the primary schools and
engaging with young people prior to
obviously they're moving into year seven
I was there
I do apologize I'll look it up
um I mean like in regards to enforcement
so obviously there's the engagement and
the visibility on but we are warranted
officers and we have a job to do in
regards to enforcing crime and
preventing crime
so we also execute and continue to
execute a number of warrants and other
policing enforcement initiatives in and
around the Malden District in um in the
various areas that we uh relevant
information and intelligence to support
such activity and we regularly use our
stop and search powers to tackle violent
crime and that sees multiple weapons
being carried on the street and um those
sort of figures are fed back through the
independent Advisory Group
um that I know that um councilors are
aware of and we've also done a number of
initiatives in relation to drink drug
and uninsured drivers as well which has
seen some uh some positive arrests um
and enforcement speed checks so I know
that it's already come up um this is
something that I think we are increasing
our activity around
um particularly in some of the more
rural parts and Rural Villages within
the Malden District
um officers from my team are out in
Clarks this morning
um doing a speed enforcement check
um and that was a a planned activity
that we obviously we try and move around
the district as much as we're able and
what I would say is that we respond to
information that we receive so um we are
very much dependent on yourselves and
your constituents and the people that
live within the communities to tell us
where these issues are
um because it is obviously as you can
appreciate there's a number of Roads um
around the district and we can't always
be in the same you know in every place
all the time so thankful to yourselves
um as I've had Communications from from
at least some of you in regards to this
issue and also to the community around
letting us know where these issues are
and slightly disappointed that it's got
one of my officers without hat on when
all the others have as that's what it
should be like
um I will feed that back to that officer
is on the back yes indeed the number is
on the back
um
in addition to that we we we're very
conscious that um you know whilst we are
the local policing response we also have
um a wider police family that we can
draw upon that have got significant
resources and specialisms
um one of those that we particularly
utilize and work closely with within the
modern districts is the rural engagement
team
um they're a team that work out of Borum
um and they work specifically in regards
to dealing with and well I was going to
say tackling them but I won't say
tackling dealing with rural issues and
Rural crime
um and you'll see there there's some
some uh things on the um on that slide
in regards to some of the stuff that
they do so they do have some engagement
elements to what they do
um there they are looking all very
professional in front of a police marked
tractor that's been loaned to us in
order to assist in in some of the
engagement we've done but actually there
really are very effective in dealing
with some some quite key rural issues in
regards to hair coursing
um Rural Road Safety
um unauthorized encampments and some
sort of wildlife and Heritage crime as
well in fact it's not in the slide
because it happens so so recently but we
the rural engagement team not for the
morning District but um in in the
district not too far away
um secured the first dog Banning order
in England and Wales
um for hair coursing only this last week
it was the very end of last week so um
you know they really are setting the
trend and blazing the trail for others
to follow
um so that's really really positive for
them but we do really work closely with
them in Malden and I'm very appreciative
of the support that they provide to us
locally and then essentially there's a
little bit there on on hair course and
as I say the um the the presentation was
prepared prior to the um the most recent
story around the the dog prevention
order that they got but um you can see
that there's a there's a whole Force
operation and it's also an operation
that's in collaboration with neighboring
forces as well that suffer similar
issues
um and we may quite regularly utilize
local resources as well to support that
so that's a real key Focus for us from a
you know rural crime perspective
um that's my presentation I appreciate
there might be questions and there might
be things that people want to ask me in
general terms so I'll leave that out
there because oh no I won't actually
because I figured that you might want to
see the teams so bear with me a second
just close this down
there we go that's better
um so that was my presentation share but
I appreciate this is going to be there's
going to be questions so I'll leave it
to you to moderate
thank you
yeah I got you as well
right councilor Morley first
yeah thank you that's
um really nice you to come and present
that last time we spoke actually was
about the hair course you know I
couldn't believe how you had got it down
and I won't ask you how did it because
it's obviously part of your tactics but
um being a farmer as well I have noticed
it if I haven't seen any on around our
land at all anything and I have spoke to
other
farmers and they haven't so I'll have to
commend you on what Ian and that's
obviously got to
help with other forms of crime because
they're not casing the joint and things
like that so um
do you feel it's a trend that you can
not Trend but is it something you can
hopefully keep
tabs on as it were really you know going
forward thank you
thank you councilor and I think I can go
into some of the tactics I think one of
the key things for me and it was a real
eye-opener for me as a young officer
um where I was dealing with a hair
coursing incident
um speaking to the farmer I had no
appreciation for the fact that that hair
coursing incident wasn't just about the
hair coursing I think they'd call
something like 50 000 pounds worth of
damage to the crops so you know there's
a real significant impact outside of
just you know the wildlife element to it
and that was a real eye-opener for me
when I was quite young in service
um so it is something that Essex police
really do take seriously and it is a
priority for us both in more than and
other rural areas
um I think there has been a significant
amount of improved tactics and some of
that's Technology based you know we've
got a lot more access to drones they've
become a lot more affordable
um we've got a significantly better
um working relationship with neighboring
forces in regards to intelligence
sharing and other things like that
um and as well once you know it's like
anything isn't it I suppose once we take
that tough stance and we set our storm
that and and it becomes known within a
certain community that it's not
necessarily another hair coursing
community that it's not something that
that they want to come to Essex for then
they tend to go elsewhere so
um I think it's something that we can
hopefully maintain there's certainly the
infrastructure and the resources to
maintain it it's not a surge
um as a result of surge activity is a
result of a long plan with Mr State
sustained resources
um so I'm confident that we'll we'll
continue to see it
um reduce thank you
councilor heard councilor Morgan and
councilor Mayes
and thank you thank you chairman
I'm uh
I'm going to continue with the praise
um first of all I'm very happy for
police to tackle crime that's that's
your job so well done and thank you for
that and I certainly applaud I certainly
applaud the use of hats as an ex-police
officer myself you always put your hat
on it gives you the authority and and
that so
well done for that
um I will say I've I've certainly seen
more police about your visibility is
very good only only yesterday I saw
officers walking in the High Street I
even stopped to say Well done nice to
see you so that's so whatever you're
doing is going well
um and I'm really pleased not only that
you're here tonight but also at Town
council meeting Sergeant dog is coming
along giving excellent presentation as
well so as always you have to be seen to
be believed and you are being seen so
that's good that's the good bit okay
I'll try and cushion I'll try and
cushion this one
um
so I've looked at the at the Malden at
the Malden crime figures and and I know
we always say that we're relatively low
crime uh as compared to the whole the
whole of Essex but we are still seeing
Rises uh in violence with injury
violence without injury sexual offenses
robberies theft and vehicle offenses
um of the 39 columns that there are
there
um 18 of them are green and 19 are red
that is an improvement though because
it used to be kind of a sea of red uh so
so and I know you can't just suddenly
change it and it becomes green but but
things are moving in the in the right
direction I do believe
um so uh the questions that I've got
then
um
uh I've done I've done those uh it
really relates to the the bottom bottom
of the page which is on the Malden
figures and these are drug offenses uh
now it's saying that there is there were
15 drug offenses in 2022
which I think is very very low that's
trafficking
um
and 27 in 23. so bearing in mind we're
only week eight uh of uh of 2023 but we
seem to have nearly double the amount
that there was in the whole of 2022 and
as far as possession of drugs goes 64 in
and 73 in 2023 again we're only uh you
know if unless you're taking it from a
different quarter that may well be the
case but what I would like to know is
that your stop and search figures
um
are those drug figures really that low
because the more you look for drugs the
more of a drugs problem you appear to
have if you don't look for it then it's
very easy to say we don't have a drugs
problem here so I'm just a little bit
concerned about the low number of drug
seizures
or the sudden increase in it I wonder if
you could help me
thank you counselor um so the first
thing I'll do is I'll clear up some
ambiguity over the the data because I I
think it's not entirely clear I I look
at this and interpret it and know
exactly what it means because I see it
every day so so essentially what it's
saying there is that's the rolling 12
months from January 2021 to January 2022
and that's in the column 2022
and then the rolling 12 months from
January 2022 2022 to January 2023 so
it's comparing 12 months to 12 months so
those 27 trafficking of drugs was it
between January or the first of February
essentially in 2021
sorry 2022 to January this year
um so that's so it's not an eight week
period
um the second thing I would say is
you're you're absolutely right in
regards to these these figures are
predominantly
um as a result of proactive police
activity
so um you're correct if that we're not
looking for it then these will be very
low and we won't find it and there's
always a very subjective question around
well if these are going up or down does
it mean we've got more or less of a
problem because actually these could be
going up because we're doing more around
it and we're detecting it more
similarly if they're going down it might
not actually be a bad thing in that
we're not doing as much it might just be
there isn't as much of a problem so
there is some subjectivity to these
um what I can tell you from a local
context is that the drug possession and
drug dealing which is essentially the
drug trafficking
um column is a priority for not only
Essex police but for my team and we have
seen an increase in our policing
activity in our policing response
um largely but not exclusively as a
result of a very a very serious incident
of violence prior to Christmas just in
one of the parks locally
so that incident so whilst the
investigation the criminal investigation
is is ongoing in relation to that there
is a proactive policing arm attached to
that that my team particularly the
Malden town center team are leading on
around how we um identify
um proactively stop and then deal with
um individuals We Believe linked to the
issues that caused or a cause of that
violence which has resulted in some drug
activity as well so there is on both
points you're correct
um there has been an increase in police
activity so that's probably going to be
why there's been an increase in the
numbers
um but I see that as a positive
um I don't think that there's less or
more of a drug issue in more than there
was 12 months ago I just think as I say
we are we've certainly increased the
amount of activity that we're doing
around it
okay well just to say Jim thank you very
much indeed for that uh I have to say
overall I'm pleased with the way the
figures are you know they are going the
right way I hope that they carry on to
do that so carry on doing what you're
doing thank you Council Morgan and
councilor most and then councilor um
Bill and then councils
yeah thank you Mr chairman uh and again
thank you for the report my
um question really concerns uh Manning
levels uh I was at a presentation by the
pfcc some weeks back and during it there
seemed to be a suggestion that cpsos
were being either not recruited or
indeed in some cases being sort of done
away with as a method of saving money so
I'd be interested to know if if that is
a case and also with regards to the
Manning level for the Malden 10 we're
about there's a as you're probably aware
a very large Housing Development going
on in haybridge which will considerably
increase into the population there have
the Manning levels for the Malden Town
station been set with that in mind
thank you
thank you councilor
um in answer to your first question I am
not aware of any reduction in community
sport officers
um I think the last reduction in
community support offices was in 2015
2016 I think
um I can assure you that we are
continuing to recruit we're not
increasing numbers we are recruiting to
maintain numbers
um and whilst there isn't a newly
recruited Community Support Officer at
Malden I have at least one newly
recruited Community Support Officer on
my team at Chelmsford so there's no
reduction in numbers there's a
maintaining of the level but there's no
increase of the current establishment of
Community Support officers in relation
to resourcing numbers there's a very
complicated algorithm that is is based
around the Census Data around how many
numbers of police officers per that 1
000 population
obviously we know that the census is as
recently been done in census terms um
whether there will be a change in the
resourcing levels allocated to the
Malden District as a result of the new
census data when those figures are rerun
I honestly don't know
um in relation to your direct question
I'm not aware of any consideration
around an increase in resource in
numbers based on the new development
specifically in haybridge any increase
or reallocation of resourcing numbers
within policing is predominantly done
around
um the Census Data
right so there could well be a shortfall
for some period until such time as a
potentially thank you
that's amazing
thank you Mr chairman
um yes visibility is great
spot on and that includes speeding
because I have to uh declare that I was
caught speeding there we go I know so
have I
so so so so so yeah well you know
um they're doing their job so that's
really good to see
um and they are all over the place so
it's not just
um on on my regular routes it's on other
routes that I don't travel very often
um
this really brings me on to anti-social
Behavior and the definition of what
antisocial behavior is
um with regard to the motor car and in
particular parking on Pavements
it is the bane of my life
um I open my inbox and I have a dozen
um emails about what are you going to do
about parking on pavement obviously our
um sep uh partners are not able to deal
with it because we don't have the
legislation there
um I have sent emails and and and you
have been very responsive
how can we stop it though
how can we stop it because they are
belligerent
um people who are doing it time and time
and time again to the point where I'm
particularly in relation to my ward
which is uh the High Street and and down
the hill and along Causeway I have
people that have no other method of
getting anywhere because people park on
the Pavements they have to go into the
road Causeway is a very busy road I have
a school uh just off the High Street
very busy
people use the the back road uh from one
the top of the High Street into the High
Street it's a bit of a cut through
really really
um difficult to deal with and this isn't
if this is not just about getting to the
the the the those that are doing it
they're doing it time and time again
they are regulars
more on Beacon Hill both sides of the
road Dreadful
um so we need to do something about it
we need to be proactive
um I stop
I use my voice and it goes away for a
little while thank you
um so it would be good to perhaps um
have something a little more proactive
uh or on that particular aspect
stop and search
um we get the figures but we don't know
and I think we have spoken about this
before
um where when and what do you actually
recover
um that then informs us as to what the
problem is with stop search
nowhere in any either report was there
anything about modern slavery
um it's only something that I've really
really recently over the last three or
four years become more aware of and and
I do have some concerns in the town
about modern slavery
um yeah I never seem to see very much
reference to it other than policy
documents
um on what we're supposed to do or going
to do but I get there are no figures
um is it a problem in this County in
this District in this town I don't know
it's like like many things you know
domestic abuse it's it's hidden
um and and that that slightly concerns
me which brings me on to women's safety
something that I always bang on about
every single year as you know Spencer
um and I've been I'm very excited that
you know we're actually now going to
take that forward and and make it more
of a priority women are afraid to be
women
we are afraid to be women now and walk
around in safety and we need to feel
safe
not me personally
but there are plenty of women out there
who don't feel safe women and girls and
won't walk about even even during the
day alone and that can't be right
not in Malden modern of all places
Croydon sorry Croydon Crime City
I wouldn't walk around in Croydon alone
but here we should be able to
and I don't understand why we're not so
the fact that we're doing something is
great so thank you very much
you want to respond to that
thank you councilor I will try and
remember all of that so if I'm if I
forget something or I miss something in
my answer please do let me know so um in
relation to parking parking is a
challenge as we know and it's not just a
challenge for for for ourselves within
policing because it's not something that
we have a legislative power in which to
enforce unless you're in the
um the confines of London where it is
illegal to park on a pavement
um we do have certain powers under
um other legislation around obstruction
of a highway which is is as far reaching
as that's the legislation that we used
predominantly for the protesters on the
M25 and another chunk ropes so there is
there are some things that we can do
around it I think the other issue is as
well is whether or not
um
we're utilizing our partners in sep as
well as we perhaps could be and that's
you know from a police perspective and
that conversation and those discussions
um because some of the parking on a
pavement whilst I appreciate if there's
no double yellow or singular lines they
can't enforce but if there are they can
um
the challenge with obstruction of the
highway is it's got It's it's required
you were quite you're required to have
to prove it to the to the criminal
standard of Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
um which requires there to be no free
Passage
beyond that vehicle or by the side
everything so it's got a block or you
know block free passage and that's at
the discretion of the officer or the the
community Sports when they attend but
it's not to say that we can't deal with
it as an obstruction
but we need to make sure that we have
evidenced it and we've got sufficient
evidence to a criminal standard in order
for it to be
um convicted at a court of law
um I think there are things that we
might be able to do and and I want to be
very clear that that we don't police
parking and we wouldn't we haven't got
the legislation to police parking
and I don't think if the public
um were asked they would want our police
officers and our community support
officers to to exclusively do parking
and I think that we would all accept
that however where we have persistent
issues with businesses or persistent
issues with individuals and there's an
element of it causing antisocial
Behavior then we do have possib the
possibility of legislation under the
antisocial Behavior act that we can take
action
um community policing Community
protection warnings and Community
protection notices so if you've got
issues like that there would have to be
the anti-social link because in itself
it's the parking isn't an anti-social
act unless it is causing either
something anti-social or it's the manner
of his parking is international so there
are options
um they're not clear-cut there is no
definitive police power for parking on a
pavement outside of London
um but it's something that I'm willing
to explore with yourselves and and my
team to see how we can perhaps look to
try and respond in a slightly more
proactive way without
get into a position where we are the
first ones from a policing point of view
that that is to deal with parking issues
which essentially we know sep are the
primary Agency for that
um you know I'm happy for my team to get
involved and assist where we can and
where it's appropriate but we would need
to be at the you know the further end of
the scale where it's become a real
endemic and any social issue
um that was the parking
um I'm just trying to think what else
there was this stop search stop search
yes as you're aware counselor you and I
and the members of the iag are in
discussion over the level of detail
um I think that's on the agenda for the
next iag isn't it
yes it has put been put on there now
yeah um I am more than happy to provide
whatever information we have within
police systems to because we're open and
transparent to yourselves and to the iag
I just need to know what it is that you
want and and how deliverable that is
um once I have that that's what you'll
get
brilliant thank you
um
sorry modern slavery modern slavery yes
right so
modern slavery is is challenging in so
much as you're right it can be hidden it
can also be quite overt but there are
more than one types of modern slavery so
you've got modern slavery where you've
got servitude within domestic addresses
you've got businesses that pop propagate
it potentially more than others uh
there's all different types of one
slavery
um I think we have to be cognizant of
the fact that it may be one of those
um crimes that police and other agencies
don't necessarily publicize their
activity around too much because there's
always that inherent risk to victims or
other victims that might be associated
with that particular Endeavor so we have
to be careful about how we do
communicate our work around modern
slavery and what I can do is assure you
that there is work ongoing and that we
do react to Community Information and
intelligence around concerns that they
may have that of particular premises
addresses
um and um you know I won't be able to
give details in this forum but I know
that there's activity planned in the
near future in regards to Modern slavery
um not necessarily in the modern
District but that I'm aware of so it is
something that we do tackle it's
something that forms part of our local
task in within police and with the
community safety partnership so it is
taken seriously but I do take on board
your comments around it being not as
visible but there are sometimes
legitimate operational policing reasons
why we can't be as vocal around that uh
yeah I appreciate that I I think it was
the fact that there was no reference to
it whatsoever and actually
um you know even if it's only a
paragraph of you know we do take it
seriously this is something that that is
ongoing and and does happen everywhere I
think that was really where I was coming
from
um thank you the the only other thing
that if I could come back Mr chairman is
um have or does uh Chief Constable lobby
at all regarding legislation for parking
on pavement Pavements
um sep would do it and are happy to do
it
um but the legislation's obviously not
there we know that it exists in draft
form but
for some reason it doesn't never seems
to come forward and sometimes it's
lobbying further up the tray that would
actually get it onto the statute Books
Okay
so my honest answer is cancer I don't
know if the chief constables lobbies for
it um I suppose the the most appropriate
person within the policing family that
would would Lobby for that type of
legislation would be the police fire and
crime commissioner
okay next
Mr Holmes she wanted to answer the
parking uh well obviously just to add to
what was said really yeah obviously we
work with the um with the police and
obviously the set um it's been quite a
while since then the parking partnership
invited here and it might be useful
perhaps in the October meeting to come
along because it might be something by
then we could have had some discussions
with sep and then we might be able to
give you some bit more information so if
members are happy with that I could send
an invitation thank you that's the bill
you've forgot now yeah
right a couple of things the um
what was it well with with this the
modern slavery and whatever
um I know that the police are doing
something about it because I report it
as a situation down in Hillary close
um where and I think it's the guys that
work at the car wash
in in haybridge and the doors always
left open they don't shut it so they
either shut the door and it bounces open
or whatever and I noticed there was a
couple of police cars down there I think
it was Saturday and uh they screamed
around a lot we was gonna everyone was
gonna get raided and I went oh
something's happening well it turned out
they went into the I think they actually
went into the house
and on on the strength of that they they
went down to the two car washes and
raided demo link so yes they are doing
the stuff
uh
I wouldn't ask Google counselor May so I
think she's as safe as houses nor would
I and uh
and and uh
and also with the car parking she she
either needs to move to London or uh
Scotland because it is law they're not
to park on the Pavements as as the
inspectors actually said but I think the
government are looking at parking on
Pavements as something to to actually
action I mean I've got a situation with
my next door neighbor he's got about six
or seven vehicles and he sent me can you
park on the path I said no
right
autonomic cars this guy can drive at
once but he's got like a whole Fleet
here and he's he's upset a lot of
neighbors so that is really anti-social
behavior and sometimes the The Refuge
stories really have a job to get through
there
but uh that was that I'd also like to
compliment the um
I don't know if you know personally do
you know Rosie
not Jim Rosie
well basically that team is very very
approachable
they've had a lot of info or information
from certain people
um I don't want to say any names because
it's all recorded but they've had a lot
of Intel
and as you'll know there is a lot of
drug activity down in Hillary close and
that unfortunately but uh there you go
you know I get dizzy watching them go
past
but um at the end of the day I think you
are right that the reason that the
figure's gone up with the drugs is
because you'll be more interactive I
honestly believe that
um and what was the other things
um I'd like to thank there was a lady
coming I think she was in the police I'm
sure she was she came to the luncheon
Club a couple of months ago and did a
presentation and that really really went
down well I'm a volunteer there with a
CVS and they were talking about romance
fraud but I mean most were about 100
years old so that's probably never going
to happen but
um there's still hope for me yeah I know
but anyway that went down really really
well the romance fraud you know making
sure you haven't got someone stood
behind you and it really really did go
down well so thanks ever so much for
that it did go down well and as I said I
go to quite a few of the community
events you know like with Bruce with his
Crime Stoppers and I thought I'd mention
that for you Bruce
he does his Crime Stoppers and and we
you know we down the prom they've been
to the community at haybridge Plantation
Hall and it is normally really really
well attended
and I have noticed the rural team about
a lot so that's good to see because like
to me it's you know it is a deterrent in
itself
I remember there was a young Romanian
girl I think it was she's not with you
anymore
but basically she was is it a cpsa
or PC I don't know what it is it's some
sort of four syllable thing anyway but
she was really really good you know she
mixed in the community she got a lot of
intel on different stuff going around
and that really does work more so in the
rural areas I mean I know hey which
isn't classed as rural because once
we've had all these houses built I'm
going to apply for heybridge to be a
city but
um at the end of the day
the cpsos do a really really good job
because they're very very visual you
know they're on a bike but possibly use
them if you can using your regular
offices to take them out or something
and then do like you said all Thorn or
something
because then it's it's a it's a very
visual thing and then people start
noticing that they can see people
and and I think Council has heard right
I've seen them up the town as well I'm
thinking oh that's good
I don't think they should be holding
hands but
but yeah I mean it's really all positive
it's the fact that I can honestly see a
lot more police about and that is
reassuring
well I mean I actually witnessed an
accident yesterday I couldn't believe it
I was in the um Library car park and
some guy I heard this big bang and I
looked up and this guy had driven over
the front wheel of one of these scooter
things with a young girl
how the hell she never got hurt I don't
know but she'd never write that again
but uh yeah
it's I I'm just really pleased the
amount of visual visualization out there
now and the community teams they do a
fantastic job I mean it's the try lead
is it Liz we're trying
he was making soup but that one I know
he's he put his hand to anything
but yeah the Community Days really
really do work they really really do so
thank you for that
in the open days we used to have Finnish
poppies I don't know what they're called
now but we don't see them anymore we
just see police cars go
and that's about it
I'm not very good at sounds
suspense do you want to carry on
let me go to counselor hurt yes that's
fine okay so first of all
um thank you for the report because that
was really informative and actually the
thing um with regard to hair coursing is
also important of course for the welfare
of the animals involved as I I have a
rescued haircut
um so and he's now 14 and has led a very
nice life since she was was rescued
because I often Escape as you probably
know and are very vulnerable to Road
accidents and all sorts
um but moving on from that our councilor
Morley has asked the question I was
going to ask about the haybridge garden
suburb and whether or not we'd get extra
um policing for that because it is a
worry
um and I think the Census Data that's
obviously going to be kind of a decade
out of date by the time it gets looked
at so that is a concern but one of the
things I did want to ask you about here
and I noticed that there has been and
which bucks are trained for for the
whole um County
um a little bit of a decrease in
residential Burger is which is great
because that probably indicates really
good work with um residents but one of
the things and it's I know it's like it
in other places too but um
you when you look at the solve rates and
actually they're a little bit lower than
the um Essex wide figures
um for burglaries particularly
residential and they're always either
under or just around five percent
um and so I'm going to ask I know it's
been in in the Press quite a lot
recently in terms of whether or not you
actually attend residential burglaries
and having experienced myself having an
elderly parent who's been burgled and
they're absolute distress that that can
cause being feeling safe in their own
home I just wanted if you could tell us
what the Essex police policy is on
attending residential Burgers
particularly thank you
thank you councilor um obviously I'm
very aware
um of some of the the you know the the
other initiatives that might have been
put in place in other police force areas
around residential burglaries and I've
seen some of the headlines as a result
of that
um what I can do is I can assure you
that um residential burglaries on Essex
police's Force plan it's one of our
priorities is one of the chief
constables priorities as well as the
pfcc's and practically speaking I can I
can assure you that we do attend every
burglary
um the only reason we wouldn't
necessarily attend the burglaries if the
homeowner's not present which obviously
and then we would attend when they were
um we also run and to give you an
illustration of this
um when overnight there's obviously
obviously we work 24 hours but there's
always a senior officer that works
overnight as the force duty officer it's
been me on occasion
um if we've got a residential burglary
that comes in overnight and we don't
have all of our necessarily resources on
because you can appreciate it's
overnight so we do have a lot of
resources on but not the main body of
resources on all the time and if we
can't allocate a unit today it comes to
me to allocate a unit and to find
someone as the as the senior officer on
duty and if we don't allocate a unit or
I don't find a unit I know that I'm
going to get a phone call from the chief
Constable the next day to find out why
we haven't attended that so I can
guarantee you that that dwelling
burglaries are a real a priority for
Essex police and they and it is
something that that is it translates
operationally as well as it being on the
force plan as they all do so no it
really is a property thank you
um thank you chairman uh
just to answer a previous question I
know that the the force establishment is
now
3755 offices that's 900 more from our
lowest figure
uh but as I said to the police and crime
commissioner it's okay to have those
police officers and as I said the work
that you're doing at the moment is right
and because those figures are turning
green but as has been raised
um it's the solved figures that we want
to see raised as well and obviously
that's really uh once we've got the
crime under control we then need to look
at how the solved rates are uh that was
just to clarify a further point but my
question is
um yeah there is a question
um street lights and this may have
something to do with the uh with the
community safety partnership
um the street light in the in the close
that I live in uh hasn't been working
for some weeks now
um and it has plunged that area because
it's the only light there Into Darkness
um so
even if these are reported it does seem
to take an age for Essex County Council
to come along so is there something that
the community safety partnership can do
to speed up those requests uh I mean
because because in fact there's three
lights out in the road that I live in
and they don't seem to be being fixed
personally I haven't reported them
personally and one could argue well why
haven't I yes and I'll do that tomorrow
right but
I have reported them in the past and
potholes Etc
um but what I'd like to know is is that
something that the community safety
partnership can encourage the the
highways authority to do because
um it does come under those priorities
of road safety even if it's just walking
along the road
foreign
I wish I had a positive response for you
now
um yes we can encourage
um then to uh I mean one one of the
things the the County Council
um
have committed to and this is around the
uh violence against women and girls
agenda I mean one of the pieces of work
which I spoke very briefly about in the
report was a operation Minerva whereby
uh we have a data mapping tool which was
produced by Nottingham Trent University
whereby we're looking at Maps across the
whole of Essex including Malden we were
looking at the Malden maps on Monday
where there's uh areas of female
victimization
and I think one of the commitments from
the County Council is if those areas are
chosen us areas of concern they'll um
fix the street lights more promptly in
those areas
so that that's that but you know that is
a County Council commitment rather than
a district one I mean yes we are in my
role
um
foreign
particularly with my Chelmsford hat on I
continuously Lobby the County Council to
get some lights fixed in the city center
some of them have taken a while to fix
um but yes it's it's something we're
happy to happy to Lobby on I'm not sure
what response we'll get but we'll be
happy to do that
thank you Mr chairman
um The Herbert protocol
I hadn't heard about it until today
uh and I think it's wonderful
um it's probably better if you explain
what it is rather than me because I've
only just found out about it
um and I'm particularly enthused by it
uh it with my
um dementia awareness hat on and being
Vice chairman to the local modern
dementia friendly Community
um
my question is actually how many times
do officers use this protocol
um and how successful is it when it is
used
sounds brilliant
thank you councilor I wasn't expecting
that one this evening
um let's find out about it now yeah so
so I I'm probably going to um do it a
very very bad disservice but I will do
my absolute best
um so the Hobart protocol chairman and
councilors is something that was put in
place
um not necessarily exclusively and
ethics it's something that was put in
place across policing a little while ago
and it is
um a set of procedures and processes in
order to improve our response and better
support vulnerable people within the
community are who are
more inclined that if they were to go
missing they would be of significant
risk to themselves I you know elderly
people or people who are vulnerable
through mental illness or mental ill
health or who have Dementia or similar
type
um medical conditions whereby they can
become confused disorientated or lost
um so the Herbert protocol was put in
place and essentially in practicality
counselor we have Miss perlier or
missing persons I use them in that
because they're missing persons liaison
officers in each district
um and they are the ones that generally
do all their liaising with social adult
social care
um the safeguarding teams and and we can
utilize The herbal protocol by putting
police records so we have an already
built up profile of our end of an
individual so that we can make sure that
when if that person was to be reported
missing we would know what medication
they need where they're likely to places
they might likely go and also um
anything that we might might assist us
in locating them so we've already got
photograph of them that we can do a
media release really quickly things like
that but there's also other things that
we can put in place as well in
partnership with some of our colleagues
in Social care which is trackers tracker
devices that they can be given and where
um or um on their phone or on their
person
um it can be a challenge because
obviously they've got to have it on them
you know but I am I'm aware of
no I'm afraid not
um but but no I am I am personally aware
of instances where vulnerable adults
have been located by police or family
members very quickly as a result of the
steps that are taken around the Herbert
protocol in fact
um it's one of the first questions we
have if we have that type of missing
person reported to us and one of the
first questions we have is are they are
they on the Halibut protocol and if they
if they are do we have any means with
which we can try and Trace their
location quickly similarly the officers
can refer people into the process as can
social Partners in Social care so if we
have someone that's reported missing for
the first time because as we know
unfortunately some of these conditions
can can take really quickly and come on
quite fast
um then we can refer people into that
process if we have that for initial
missing episode
uh thank you through you Mr chairman and
the last uh or just to come back is um
do officers locally
um I mean I would hope at all levels
have formal
um you know whether it's an air session
or whatever uh to become a dementia
friend
we do significant amount of training
around awareness of mental health issues
and vulnerabilities within the community
as part of our ongoing continuous
professional development
um dementia awareness we do have a
dimensional awareness program within
Essex police is one of the support
groups and they do regular talks and
regular training sessions we also have
it I would suggest from memory
we it's not a specific bespoke training
package to dementia only it's part of a
wider vulnerability adult vulnerable
adult package that we have that is
taught and is part of our not only
initial training but part of our
continuous professional development
chairman lovely thank you
councilor Morley just to say yes
brilliant idea I had a great I had a
grandfather went missing he was a bit I
had a bit of Dimension just couldn't
find him and um we found him on the
reservoir layer but
I I take your point you know if you if
you don't know where they are if you
just give them a little tag or a
bracelet or something be marvelous I
think it's brilliant
anyone else
well I need to say this is not really on
the agenda chairman I mean it's nice
nice to know but it's not really on the
agenda so can we move on yeah
Tesla bill
German it's just me being nosy actually
because that's what I do
um
with with the um it just amazes me
because I don't know why I suppose now
I'm retired I need to know everything so
I listen to a lot of news it's amazing
how many young it really surprised me
how many young people go missing
there don't seem to be many weeks at all
where there's someone just disappeared
never to be heard of again I mean it
totally amazes me and I don't know how
Saint councilor May's write about the
dementia thing there is something they
can wear
I think and it basically
it they say push this and then it
actually gives them a
um the phone number
so that that's the way they can do it if
you find someone that doesn't really
know what the you know it it's not
pretty obvious that they don't know what
they're doing or where they are there is
a I think there's a button they they do
and it actually does
tells them who who the person is and it
also gives them the phone number thank
you and the other thing is
there seems to be a lot have you found
since the lockdown thing that you've got
a lot more domestic abuse and the
coercive manipulation thing or whatever
because people can't couldn't get out at
the time
um
thank you councilor the question would
be the answer will be in two parts
um the first part around the coercive
and controlling Behavior that's new
legislation so there's very little for
us to track with it historically because
it's not something we would have
recorded previously so when I say it's
new in legislative terms it's relatively
new
so it's very difficult for me to say
that it's more prominent because it's
not something we recorded before
um I think it's always been there I
think it's just now that we are starting
to record it I think we'll be able to
track it a little bit better over coming
years as to whether or not it's going up
or down
um in relation to domestic abuse
um
lockdown and the the times that we had
during the relative covid lockdowns was
was a strange time in policing so much
as it did some strange things to our
crime data and obviously the whole
society changed um you know almost
overnight for a period of time what I
can say around domestic abuse is that
that Essex police has actually seen two
months of reduction in the amount of
domestic abuse that we've had reported
so um for the first time in a very long
time I think first time in about six or
seven years perhaps
um
no I don't think it is I think that you
know it's a real significant Focus
across this experience and other
partners around tackling domestic abuse
um and I think that that's starting to
bear fruit and I think you know
ultimately whilst we're not suggesting
that that we're you know we're all going
out for tea and medicine or anything
like that it's just we have
the data is there we're not we are
getting less domestic abuse reported to
US unless domestic abuse recorded
um and they said there's so much work
going on around it in Essex police so
amongst other partners as well so I
think that what we're seeing is some of
the longer term benefits of that
significant approach being taken across
statutory authorities in relation to
domestic abuse
all right we've had um several accidents
in Malden Road Lexington
um
sometimes police cars come from Harlow
all over the place but not from molden
and the other night we had one and they
came from stanway
a point of order again this is not on
this is really not on this is a crime
and disorder committee and I think we
should move to the next business if you
don't mind
I think you're rather rude to talk to a
chairman like that it's not on
I'm just saying it's not on it's not on
the it's not on the commit it's not on
there however several people who asked
questions that aren't on the agenda and
this is about crime and statistics stole
the rest of it accidents all the rest of
it anyway I was informed that uh police
cars either come from chigwell
or stanway for the whole of Essex is
that correct
thank you chair
um so we have roads policing bases that
work at stanway in chigwell
so dependent on the nature of the
incident we will send their most
appropriate results okay so there may be
instances when it comes to road traffic
collisions where the most appropriate
response to attend that is a roads
policing vehicle because our specialist
equipment and training so they would
come from chigwell yeah as a base they
might not have been into your world but
that's where their base would have been
um because what we don't want to be in a
position where is we we might send an
officer from Malden to a crash on a fast
Road where they're not equipped with or
trained people oh just a standard that
it took 20 minutes to go stanway
selection
the risks involved in that's all yeah no
I understand right thank you very much
everybody thank you uh
any other business no there isn't uh
thank you very much
Mr Ballard and thank you very much
Mr Spencer and thank you very much Mr
Richard Holmes I now close the meeting
for Mr herd's benefit a 14 minutes past
nine
foreign